[Laughter]
hello welcome back to big mood where the
dicks are small
and the moods are big i don't want to be
here anymore if that's the case
well i'm out you want us to have large
dicks yes excuse me where the dicks are
big and the moods are
bigger they're huge the roots can be
smaller because they're big yeah
the mood small if i had what about
average
the moods are average no i want to
sling my dick over my shoulder when i
walk so i don't get rug burned
wow wait how does it what size is it
hard then it's taller than you uh it's
about
have you ever seen a stripper bowl pools
are actually modeled after my wiener
it goes up and then you climb it yeah
you climb around yeah
and then you spin yeah a nice graceful
spin i call it the king
can you make a tick tock next time that
happens absolutely
thank you uh so what we're talking about
today well
we're not talking about this the whole
episode but uh in the
world right now um jada pinkett and will
smith
have done a red table talk is it ready
people talk i've never heard it's her
show on facebook yeah
and so usually she is not the person
being interviewed that's why
it was like jada brings herself to the
red table talk
um and will sat in her spot
and uh i guess originally and i just
caught up with this but
um you know uh there's an artist named
august
and he came out about him he had his
name august
he's had a lot of coffee i'm so sorry
this is the first episode of the day
please just chill for
me for a second i'm so sorry he
basically confirmed some rumors in an
interview uh he confirmed these rumors
that
um him and jada had a relationship
and that will give permission right and
that will was like
i wish you guys the best and so it was
like
whoa before then everyone was kind of
speculating but then after that he was
like yeah that happened
and then everyone's like yo will and
jada
did it happen you gotta talk about it so
then they're like [ __ ]
well we didn't want to talk about it but
now we got to talk about it and so it
was um
how did you guys feel watching it i felt
uncomfortable
i i watched it this morning before i
came
okay and then i asked twitter to fill me
in on the rest
but from what i saw it was
a little bit no a very much awkward
conversation awkward
but it's also like this was like four
years ago and the fact that the public
brought it up now and they have to like
revisit it after i'm sure they've done a
lot of
pain but it wasn't problematic yeah it
was yeah oh august brought it up and
then
said it in his album in a song in his
elbow and then that's how it got brought
up in the interview
yeah and also there was this music video
i forgot which
which one but in the music video it it
shows him texting someone
and then the person's name the contact
is jada's middle name
and then so even like in the text
conversation of that music video it kind
of like insinuates that
it could have been jaded i'm surprised
like because there's been rumors about
them having an open relationship for so
long and we know
will has been banging someone else i
mean come on you know for sure that
dude's been
i mean that's why during the red table
talk he was like oh or like
you said you wanted revenge and then she
was like i think you got your ribbon
yeah and then he's like no i didn't
but i i'm surprised like because it
seems like august is the one that's been
like kind of blowing this
like out into the public or whatever
like did he not have an nda or anything
because you would think like
such a high-profile marriage yeah
a-listers would have ndas and like he
kind of just
i it seemed to me from their red table
talk that they were kind of embarrassed
and really didn't want this to get out
right you explain to people what an nda
is just in case they don't oh
non-disclosure agreement which means you
agree not to talk about certain things
in a row like when you sign a contract
yeah there's a lot of celebrities with
kinks
that um have i know an escort a former
escort
she used to do a lot of uh celebrity
kinks
and yeah they have ndas that they sign
uh i'm sure all the ones that will slept
with signed ndas because where are all
those [ __ ] at
why don't we hear from them sure i have
one more
dead serious like uh my attorney's like
hey you should have i haven't signed
well i didn't sign it gina's house yeah
because like
i had like um this organizer decorator
come in and she like organize and
decorate whatever and then she took
photos before and after and she posted
it on her
her story and i'm just like i didn't
agree to this
yeah which i mean like at the time like
all right coming up kind of whatever but
my attorney's like that's did she tag
you with it
yeah oh my god so like my turn is like
that's not okay
dude so like we drafted a whole nda and
whoever comes over to my house that has
to sign
dang yeah she lives on yeah
right five four three six her bedroom is
the third one from the left
i know all their houses i'm stealing all
their pets that's why i ain't seen [ __ ]
smart she signed the nda she knew
[Laughter]
yeah so usually i would assume they
would it sounded from the table talking
this is all speculation and
um and that's why i think i felt
uncomfortable because it felt like a lot
of private business
that nobody wanted to talk about like it
got forced out of there and it was like
kind of fake and and like rehearsed and
very cautious very cautious like they're
like oh it's so
like raw but then it was like there was
a lot more they didn't talk about
all this because there was a point where
will was like i was done with your ass
and i'm like where's the real [ __ ] you
know like what really happened it did
seem like a lot was cut out
it kind of made us want to know more
about the new stuff that got brought up
true it also looked like will was like
holding in a lot
and it kind of like his eyes looked like
his face looked pretty funny just looked
like he was like
yeah i think that's what i was picking
up on i was like this feels
uncomfortable
like these people should not have to be
talking about
something they don't want to talk about
but i get why there's a lot of pressure
from
the audience and then from like you know
the twitterverse or whatever
um so it feels like a lot of pressure
but uh it sounded like
this uh august was came to them and
and like they were mentoring him almost
um he was
young no i i think they they for some
reason i don't know why but he was very
he was very physically ill yeah seizures
like physical
i wasn't sure if they meant mental
illness or if they had liver conditions
yeah having physical illness physical
illness
illness mental illness in it wait so if
you got cured
what else are they hiding like what i
heard it was not
i heard it was a lifelong liver like
chronic illness that he's just going to
have
life long live it and yeah no
little pool no absolutely not
no but yeah no so the one direction did
i
i do kind of want to take with the
directions yeah i was like how did they
get in the comments
you guys are impossible i'm sorry it's
the first episode of the day we're all
energetic
one thing i wanted to bring up though is
how weird it is that once i realized
that he was like
22 or 24 or something and she was like
in her 40s
yeah yeah i just tried to judge credit
i mean so what i mean i was reading some
of the comments and that i was like does
anyone find this odd because um
it sounded like he went to them for help
and then it became a relationship which
does sound like
someone organic being kind of taken
advantage of but i don't want to judge
that way
because we don't know the full story i
want to know
how long do they know each other before
before they started their entanglement
entanglement that she calls it
like if it was someone that they've
known since he was like 16 that's weird
no i don't think so
you know i think from what i read like
um jayden their son just introduced them
at some point and then
they started helping see that's even
that's weird too it's like i would not
try to get in a relationship with my
son's friend
that's [ __ ] weird a little bit weird
yeah i'm not really on jay decided on
any of this like just as like a
spectator if this was some sort of
spectator sport which i know they're
real people with real lives
yeah um it to me it just seems like
really predatory really weird
um and that like he like you could tell
from august's interview that he like
absolutely fell in love with her right
right and that he was completely crushed
and it was like he went there for
healing
but she also kind of destroyed him at
the same time with this
like love she was using him for which
you could tell
yeah i mean she was using him for that
yeah i feel like you're looking for
yeah yeah have you guys ever been in a
position though where
um like you felt pretty entanglement
where you felt like kind of rejected
from your partner or things weren't
working out
yeah and so you looked for yeah yeah so
then like someone gives you some
attention
and even like you didn't mean to mess
with their
emotions but like you were also in a
vulnerable spot where like no one had
made you feel sexy in years
because i've been in that position
before where it was like
man like my boyfriend like didn't want
to have sex with me for months
and then this then he like walked out
one day and was like i'm done
and then that same day this guy from my
past came in and was like yo
like we never hooked up before but he
was like yo it was my birthday like come
hang out and watch friends with me and i
was like i don't know i'm going through
a tough time and he's like i'm just
gonna
i'll just be your best friend today and
then like we ended up hooking up
even though i wasn't but also was he
like 20 something years younger than you
and also was he physically and
slightly mentally like not fully there
and like all the air but going through
like going through you know like
so this guy had always joked about um
taking his virginity
because he was kind of like um he was
kind of like this
nerdy like uh i'm saving myself type of
person but then he ended up the best
he ended up right right yeah i was like
i'll teach you what a woman is but it
would always like play kittens
yeah i'm like they don't know anything i
don't know anything i'm just kidding
i'm sorry and it was always like you
know he's always above
he was a legal age it wasn't like
anything crazy like that um he was 18.
no he was 20. but um yeah so i always
joked like
oh when you turn 21 you know like um so
that's when he
was messaging me it was on his 21st
birthday but he never let that go
right he was waiting and he was like
it's time
yeah at that point he deserves it he
deserves it it's fine he
waited but um he had already lost his
virginity so it wasn't as
like it wasn't as fun we were just kind
of joking about it in his head though
in his head he was re-losing it to you
though i think uh right
or what if he lied about losing it he
didn't want to pressure you and that was
him losing
my point is i never would have done it
it was always like a teasing thing like
he was just like a friend you know and
like we you know
joke about understanding jada's point
i'm
kind of being a shitty person well
in my case in my case he didn't he
wasn't coming to me for healing or
anything he was full
on flirting with me it was it was just
like uh like it worked out
yeah you know you needed some attention
and he gave it to you
yeah i wasn't trying to draw a complete
parallel there but more just so like
just exploring different aspects of this
because i think it brought up several
different things
one an open relationship like would you
hook up with
would you be open to an open
relationship um no i would be
open to it if you were married for 20
years and maybe
you guys didn't want to get divorced or
separated so you were trying it
and then also this whole thing of like
have you ever
just had sex with someone to because you
felt
neglected a rebound yeah basically
a rebound yeah i've had uh something
like that before was just like after a
breakup i'm just like i feel so
blah and you just want to dump your
emotions and your feelings and feel
pretty and feel
loved even just for like a brief moment
and then but then like
i in my head i'm very aware and i would
tell them like hey you know like this is
this is just to hook up it's just
probably gonna not last like this
i just got out of a relationship and
just be very old you have a lot of
self-control because for me
um in the three serious relationships
i've ever been in
that was the situation and like i guess
i felt
i felt bad or weird about just keeping
it short so then i ended up extending it
for three years to like make it worth it
yeah like i don't i just felt like
unnecessary i know
so that's why i'm like damn it i wish i
would have known better but
um but yeah that's actually how casey
and i started too because like i had
just gotten out of
the second relationship and then i was
like hey just i'm trying
to just not be super into a relationship
especially not like a month after
breaking off an engagement because
that's a big commitment
and yeah i ended up marrying when you
when you tell them
that it's not going to be something
serious they want it more yeah
yeah they usually work you should you
should have been like
oh can we can we get married chase them
off scare them off
i know right that's what i should have
done but it's okay it works about the
whole like open
relationship thing i don't think i can
ever do that i'm not a sharing kind of
person
the same i would rip your face i'm not
either but then if it's the situation
where it's like oh we're like
40 50 or like 60 i don't know older
and i we're just bored or like i don't
know if they're really
like it gets dull and you want some
things to spice it up yeah probably
risk like what if he falls in love with
the other person he leaves
that's a scary thing yeah i think you
i so that's why i'm like i never want to
judge because
i don't want to ever say never because
what i have never been in that position
where i've been married for 20
years or whatever i have two kids and we
never have sex anymore or whatever like
i don't know the exact
specifics to where i would maybe cross
that line and be like
okay i'm open to it now i i feel like um
i always thought with the rumors of jada
and will that they had the open
relationship that you know that was the
tabloid rumors
yeah but it seems to me now that
it wasn't really that and then like
maybe will was cheating and then she was
cheating and then like the media somehow
made it seem like oh they have an open
relationship like this is you know kind
of american it's fine
america's sweetheart couple but also
look they're kind of edgy and they have
this open relationship and so i think a
lot of people
were like oh hey maybe i can do it if
they can do it
but then now as we see this red table
talk it looks like a total [ __ ] mess
and it looks like it was not good not
healthy for them
not healthy for their kids you can see
that um jaden
i feel like he was rumored to have an
eating disorder willows rumored to have
depression
like i don't think it created a good
environment for the kids so i think
now after seeing that red table talk i'm
like
even more against an open relationship
than i ever thought i would
have been for yourself for myself yeah
and and
um i just assuming if you
were like say 50s or something and you
guys went into it saying okay
we love each other so much we're just
literally gonna go get sex and we're
agreeing with that like maybe it can
work out
but i think in this instance with jada
and will like it wasn't really that
like it was a desperate kind of [ __ ]
up situation
it's a situation where it is like the
older
couple they've been married forever they
go into this open relationship
situation being like hey if we find love
in this then
cool because then at that point like if
you're gonna agree
to open up your marriage there is that
risk of you
getting feelings for someone else or the
other way around and
that's a risk that i'm pretty sure a lot
of people that are in open relationships
end up
discussing and even though they're just
like no no it's going to be us
ride or die no matter what i mean that
that is a possibility you might end up
finding
comfort or love outside of the marriage
so personally for me if i ever got to
that point where it's like hey we're
gonna open
the marriage and see where it goes i
would
for me to get to that point i would
already be okay with the possibility of
why not just get divorced why don't i
just get an escort
if it's just sex yeah if you could just
pay for it and then get because there's
a lot of high class like really
hot guys that you could pay for and it
wouldn't be some [ __ ] entanglement
that's going to ruin your marriage and
make things uncomfortable what if it
isn't just for sex what if it's like hey
i need some like
affection yeah i think you should just
get divorced
right i guess well okay well how about
this though
how old are willow and jade are the kids
yeah i feel like 20s
mid-20s early so four years ago they
would have been still
maybe living under their parents roof or
whatever i think
um because there's also this whole
argument about
how um like no matter what having two
parents in the house
uh together it has always proven to be
better for the kids
and so a lot of parents will stay
together um because
of that reason that at least well
because statistically
yeah right i mean
obviously case by case but um i i don't
know if
will and jada were arguing and screaming
but
in i mean in my parents case like they
stayed together
uh through a lot of hard times and i
didn't even know that they were going
through hard times like they would
fight behind the scenes but they never
let us know until
years later when we're all moved out of
the house and like yeah we almost got
divorced at uh when you guys were like
seven when i was like seven
and i was like whoa like i well they
were really good those are good parents
yeah they were good
so what if to save them really quick
yeah for you
being that child you didn't experience
like any of the hardships or anything do
you think
that either helped you or hindered you
when you were
viewing how to like conflict resolve for
in relationships because you didn't
really have an example to look at
like when you were in relationships
yourself and then there were hard times
like did you kind of feel like
it might have helped you if you saw an
example i think maybe it shaped my
values that like i've always been
more of a family person like i i looked
at marriage as something
that was sacred that can work out like
that because a lot of people are cynical
like they
come from divorced parents and they're
like well i don't see marriage
as being this like viable institution
that still should be around
and for me it was the opposite and same
with steve like he grew up with
his parents married the whole time and
so we've both very been like marriage
people and like we want to have
traditional family
values and um i don't think i think
that's slowly not becoming the norm
um but for both of us i do think that
really shaped
what i wanted my future to be like you
know and i think that seeing
that they could work out no matter what
it was like i do think in
subconsciously it did shape a lot and so
maybe um
i was just saying like maybe they
instead of divorcing right away
um trying alternate ways of staying
together
and keeping it you know keeping the
marriage there
at least for the kids uh until something
happens might have been the route they
were going but i can't
say but what i can say is that i got a
great ass style
and you know what you do i know where
that comes from
stitch fix yes you ever find yourself in
an entanglement but you still want to
look good
this is all stitch fix thank you stitch
thank you
i was looking at it earlier too like
these jeans fit you so well genes
no matter what body type you have
they're incredible
they work they work um they're like
stretchy
check out these jeans but they're not
like jeggings they're like just the
right stretch factor
yeah butt you get a butt like that
included
yeah well with stitch fix you uh you go
online you take a style quiz and
basically what that is it'll show you
pictures of different clothes and you
say if you like it or not and then from
that they can determine
what your kind of style is and you get
assigned to a stylist who
then picks out clothes for you you don't
have to uh you don't have to pick out
anything so if that kind of stresses you
out when you're shopping you're like i
don't know
i'm always stressed out when i'm
shopping it's the most i can see that
i'm terrible at it i can see jess in a
storage be like i'm over it
i just like people doing things for me
right well this is like a personal
stylist without
the cost of a personal stylist so you
uh pay a 20 styling fee for each fix
which is credited towards anything you
keep so if you keep a shirt for 28 bucks
that 20
goes to that shirt um so schedule at any
time there's no subscription
subscription required plus shipping
returns and exchanges are easy and free
uh get started today at stitchfix.com
mood and you'll get 25
off when you keep everything in your fix
that's stitch fix dot com slash mood for
25
off when you keep everything in your fix
stitchfix.com
that's right and so when you're looking
good you also want to
smell good too right yes i do yes you do
so
native is awesome because they actually
use ingredients you have heard of
like coconut oil shea butter tapioca
starch
unlike other deodorants how they
actually use aluminum which by the way
did you know aluminum
forms a plug in your sweat glands
and that's why like it keeps you from
sweating which is totally absolutely
disgusted right now why'd you
why did you tell me that i feel like i
feel like
yeah all my little glands got little i'm
absolutely disgusted oh god
exactly so that's why native never uses
ingredients like aluminum parabens
sulfates or talc
and so it's pretty awesome too because
they have like over 10 cents
and they rotate seasonally and so for
example my favorite is the cucumber and
mint
there's also like citrus and herbal
coconut and vanilla lavender and rose
and others
and it smells amazing like it smells
so freaking good which one's that one oh
this is the sea salt and cedar
oh the man one man manly smells so good
i got the one in the paper um
paper dispenser have you seen those old
flintstones push pop yes
ice cream is like that yeah i just
recently got mine too yeah they have the
plastic free packaging now which is
great
exactly so native is risk free to try
every product comes with free shipping
within the us plus
free 30-day returns and exchange so you
see why
so many people love native do what i did
and make the switch
to native today by going to nativedo.com
big mood or use promo code big mood at
checkout and get
20 off your first order that's
nativedeo.com
big mood or use promo code big mood at
checkout for 20
off your first order yeah smell good
because i hate people are like oh
where's my hug and then i have to hug
them and they don't smell good oh they
don't smell good
oh yeah and by the way all of this is
like so i get the snap judgments right
away like what
the like when you first see this like
obviously it looks bad on jada for sure
but i'm just trying to play like a
little bit of double advocate here um
just in case you're wondering at home
like oh my god is nikki like totally on
jada's side no matter what no i'm just
trying to like
if you go through those comments there's
a bunch of thirsty ass [ __ ] that are
like
will i would never do you like that much
better
i'm sure honestly has probably slept
with a lot of women besides jada and she
probably deserved
that feeling of like it's my turn you
know so i'll give her that
but i just feel like that particular
situation was just very
healthy that entanglement was just not
something to look up to like i feel like
if it was a different situation
i would be a little bit more on her side
especially when you look at his
oh sorry i don't know when you look at
like august's interview
he is so heartbroken yeah yeah he's
destroyed by that and he looks like you
guys
yeah people on twitter are saying though
like did she really do something wrong
though because they were separated and
even will said i was done with you
yeah that's wrong necessarily for their
marriage but i i just feel like i
definitely get this feeling like she
really
used this august this year yeah um the
one well
i i feel like she was wrong for using
him for
her emotional advantage when she needed
especially he was so vulnerable
but the whole like is was it cheating
though because they were separated
yeah and even will himself said i was
done with you like it was just you know
that could also just be a pr move too
could be to like could be
safe let's take it for surface though
yeah so would you think that's wrong
they were separated
even we were on a break we were on a
break he said i was
done with you yeah then i mean what is
she supposed to do
yeah i mean i don't know like how many
years do you go
in a separation where you're not allowed
physical touch or you're not allowed
yeah
totally and that's why i can relate on
that front yeah
um to okay well i'm not getting my needs
met in my marriage so
i'm gonna go elsewhere the person that
she went elsewhere to
i don't i know like it feels like she
used him but i don't
did she know that she was using him at
that time
enough to know also yeah i don't know
yeah i don't know because i'm like when
you get caught up in your own emotions i
mean
i can see her not realizing i don't
think she knew
yeah that she was using she talked about
her codependency issues and things like
and i
extremely relate to that i have like
i've had codependency issues my entire
life and i'm still working on those so i
get that feeling it's like
it's almost like you're com you're not
operating on logic you're not operating
even on like just the
basic level of consciousness like you're
literally just taken over by this need
yeah so i get that i get that that's the
reason why i just jumped in
right away i since i was 16 i've haven't
had more than a month of being single oh
yeah
wow yeah i said play a play-doh
so um this brings up a question that i
want to ask you guys because we
the three of you and me are on complete
total opposite
uh spectrums of this the three of us and
you yeah
um public relationships like oh
you guys are oh you haven't really had
one no i've been in relationship for
years and nobody knew
like i just don't talk about it i keep
it private yeah i mean you're so lucky
i mean i was at one point like we were
shopping for rings to get married
and yeah people never knew so
i it's things like this when i see him
like see this is why i keep my
relationship
so private absolutely me from now until
forever yeah
never well no you weren't forced i
wasn't of course i wasn't forced into
that's right these were kind of
circumstantial too because uh
so the first two relationships live in
relationships that i had during my
career like when i was already in the
public eye you know when
i was on a channel called totally sketch
and they were like super big at the time
and um i was i was in a five-year
relationship at that time
no one knew that i had a boyfriend or
who he was or anything um because he
wasn't
he wasn't in the public eye uh and then
i when we broke up
i was in another two-year relationship
and that guy lived with me
and never talked about him um people
would not know that we were in a
relationship i always say that i have a
boyfriend but i
didn't like just so vague yeah just
vaguely like nothing it was never like
look at this is my boyfriend everyone um
it wasn't until steve that it became
public because i he was already public
you know
and so that's hard to hide if and i
don't we don't want to hide it either
because
we work together all the time it'd be
weird to be like yeah we're married but
we're not going to talk about getting
married
and you're both in videos and you're
both so yeah yeah and then we found
something even greater together than i
feel like we were doing on our own which
like we have our own styles separately
but then together we have like a banter
that um
i feel like is really fun yeah in on our
podcast and stuff so
yeah it worked out that way yeah for me
i mean i was kind of like well the
reason why
i even came to the public eye is because
of my relationship with casey so there
was no way we could
not talk about it and plus i'm not i i'm
so not
obviously if you guys have been watching
this podcast long enough you know this
about me i
am so not a closed book like i i don't
know how to be
private about certain things i just
i i don't know what's in what it is
inside of me like i just feel like
like blah this is the truth here here it
is like you got it and it
backfires a lot of the times and that's
actually what i've learned from being
in the public eye from my relationship
but like talking so much about my
relationship
and that's actually something that uh
because we talked about this jada thing
recently and uh it ended up making me
realize like i do not
want to be as one thousand percent open
about our marriage anymore because it
ended up starting like the reason why i
started
being more open is because i i realized
that
we were ended we had this branding about
our our relationship
and everyone was looking up to it and
everyone was like you guys are so
perfect like all these things and it
just made me feel like an imposter like
a fraud because i'm like
hold on we have a [ __ ] ton of problems
like we're so
far from being perfect and so it gave
like it
it it started having i started having
this feeling inside of like
[ __ ] i'm i'm so fake like people don't
know who who we really are people don't
know the struggles we're really going
through
i don't want people to view us as like
something that we're not so then that's
why i started being more
open about our problems publicly and
then that ended up
backfiring completely because then
people started completely like
tearing our marriage apart and saying
like there's no way like why are you
guys even together
and just like scrutinizing every little
thing that
has been said or even like non-verbal
things like things from our
our vlogs they'll like pick apart like
oh did you see the way they looked at
each other like this and all these
winning in this situation never like i
learned that now
after having the hard lesson because
that entire situation ended up creating
this internal like
weird like social media phobia kind of
thing where
i stopped posting on social media as
much i don't
share as much as i i would like to
because now i can see the
the repercussions of it and it really
sucks because i
i would love to be open but i can't
handle what i get back so because of
that reason i'm like oh [ __ ] i gotta
protect myself a little bit protect our
marriage
because we're working on it really hard
like we're every day we get a little bit
better and
not everyone sees that and so it's the
same thing where it's like do you really
is it a good idea to tell your mom
everything that your boyfriend or
husband does that pisses you off because
she will never forgive him even
even when you do right and it just
creates an unhealthy situation what's
also hard is like when people
start taking sides based off of the
limited knowledge that they have of your
relationship because they're only
taking what what they've been shown and
then they're making a judgment off of it
and then
forever like once they decided they're
not on your side
any little thing you do it's twisted to
fit their narrative
of that you're a bad person or that you
don't deserve to be in that marriage or
whatever
i feel like that was basically my entire
relationship with joe because joe was
like
the obviously the crowd favorite the fan
favorite because he was the influencer
before i came into the picture so
anytime there was any sort of like weird
vibes on or if i was mad because of
something he did off camera but he's
able to turn on this like happy
influencer face and like be funny
then i'm just still kind of pissed off
and it's just like you know i'm this
horrible [ __ ] girlfriend that ruined
his [ __ ] life like little do people
know
i i was doing everything for him that i
possibly could you know so
yeah that i hated that you don't get to
say your side
and especially what's hard is like when
people are making comments like that
you can't go in there and defend
yourself to you yeah like then i gotta
[ __ ] tell them like oh you don't
you know what he just did do you [ __ ]
know why do i need to
tell people that right so then i just
have to sit with it and feel like [ __ ]
about it
and then it hurts your self-esteem it
does yes yeah and it
slowly killed our relationship over time
so gina's the only smart one yeah
don't change that yeah i will never
publicly have a relationship i mean i
might post a picture on instagram if i
get a boyfriend one day but
you guys will not know a goddamn thing
about it
people say things a little gina there
must be something wrong with her cause
she never has a boyfriend i'm like
no she's had plenty of boys i had
thousands
happening just because i don't talk
about it like that's the same thing with
social media just because they don't
talk about it doesn't mean they don't
exist you know what i mean it's just
that i dread
um ever having to make a post like
hey you know just like oh a whole
breakup
on two different channels sucks to suck
nerd
like i don't want to do that you know
yeah and i'm so very
um very particular like if i
if i ever want to post about my
significant other it has to be at least
like
four or five years down the line maybe
you know yeah or a picture of you
i picture you posting wedding pictures
of your wedding day
but it's only you like are you in the
like she never even shows her her yeah
is he husband or boyfriend husband
beyonce i forgot beyonce and you imagine
i'm just like but i'll put in the
caption this is
this does not mean i'm in a relationship
yeah yeah yeah disclaimer this isn't
permanent
anyway so like your wedding's gonna be
where we all dress up in wedding dresses
and no one knows he's getting married
who's the pride
um yeah so i the only time i ever went
kind of public with this was a guy that
i was just like dating briefly the
shitty one
which is like oh this is kind of fun
let's post it like we went to paris
together the one that i
i ditched in the middle of a road trip
because had to hit me i remember him
yeah that one
number remind me which one that is off
camera um it's a i made a whole video
like the worst person i ever dated we
only did it for like four months and it
was just like one it was just like
uh whatever like it's not that serious
and two it was a lot of him like so why
aren't you posting me why aren't you
posting
this guy that his entire instagram was
fake
no like he would blur himself out so i'm
like why does that matter
because he wants to be a criminal so bad
but he wasn't
um he wanted to be cool but i posted it
for funsies
and then you know people are like oh my
gosh she has a boyfriend it's just like
yeah whatever
and then it got to the whole like why
aren't they posting anymore what
happened what's going on i'm like oh
that's so annoying yeah and then i made
a video about the worst person i ever
dated which was really fun but
um and that's when i was like i really
don't want to go public because
one my a lot of my career was built on
how i looked the sex appeal the go
dancing the modeling
so to keep the fantasy alive right you
know so the
obvious marketing thing that people
always do is you know never say that
you're in a relationship
i get that but also because there's so
much of me that is public there is
something that i i
if it's like it's so precious to me that
i want to keep it private
you know um the public will ruin it the
public will ruin
something and i know the moment that if
i post a dude on my thing
girls are going to message him be like
hey which is like
dude chill you know like oh people look
up to you they will also want your man
exactly
yeah do anything they can to take it
yeah yeah and then so it's just
that's why i decided like i'm not gonna
go public unless it's something like
very like hey i'm probably gonna marry
this guy
um and i almost did with the guy that i
told you about that we were probably
gonna get married but then we didn't
eventually because i was like this is
not what i wanted
and like i said i don't want to do the
whole like hey guys you know we broke up
don't worry like we're still friends
like it's still love whatever i
don't want to [ __ ] do that yeah yeah
it's rough man being
being in the public and then it also
made me i i take all of that
and i try to spin it in a positive way
or else i'm gonna drown in an abyss of
depression
but the positive thing is so emo
oh yeah um is that like i can take all
this [ __ ] and it can make me stronger
and i can learn from it and i won't be
making the same mistakes or
if i do then i'll learn from that too
and i'll try to move on and i try to
i try to to see how also every time i
would get
like some shitty like hater
life-ruining kind of comments i i
tried to view it from a different
perspective of like okay why is this
affecting me so much what is it within
me that i haven't fixed that
is like this actually is hurting me like
what is it so then i try
my best it's not like it's really hard
to practice this but
i i really try to see where i can learn
and grow
from the things that hurt me so yeah
that's what you that's
i feel like that's so healthy you know
that's what you should do
um that's how you grow and that's how
you progress and stuff um
you know steve and i we've been together
for well i've known him for 10 years but
um we've been together for seven years
now and
like i i talk a lot about our
relationship and like it's
it's the healthiest relationship i've
ever been in it's amazing i love you
guys so much
i like i just i have your picture framed
above my bed as like
me one day are you trying to steal my
man
i'm trying to steal his wife right right
right oh that's fine
we got big dicks yeah yeah i got that
big dick energy for you i know how you
like it
my balls hang to my knees but uh i you
know i feel i find it interesting
because people are like oh my god like
how kind of you were saying like um you
know you put on a pedestal where
like people they you have a perfect
relationship blah blah but
even though it's like super healthy um i
feel like
it's not like we were perfect people
like when we got together
we fought all the first years right yeah
and we talked about this a lot but
because that was so long ago
it's not like at the forefront of where
our relationship is but that's how you
evolve and grow
um and i try to emphasize that like no
we were not perfect
for like i wouldn't say that it was like
um
oh my god like we're a perfect match we
will get along forever that first year i
really thought
like we were not going to make it so now
imagine
being on camera like we are now or on
yeah news like we are now
like constantly talking about it as
you're going through that first right
like i think you guys weren't really
super vocal about all those problems on
camera having your fans involved
no during that time it's like now you
can go back and talk about it and then
they won't really
be so affected by it because they're
like oh well they're so healthy and
happy now
that's exactly the difference too yeah
yeah yeah exactly
in fact uh steve wouldn't put me in any
of his
uh social media for the first year
because his previous relationship was
very public and he didn't like that they
had to do these breakup videos and stuff
and so i felt like he was projecting
on to me all the problems from his
previous relationship
so that caused a lot of fights too and
then i was doing the same thing
projecting onto him
a lot of the problems from my previous
relationship who he knew the guy
too like and so it was um
a lot she had a breakup video she got a
breakup video but you got a wedding
video
that's so true
i want steve to do a video reacting to
his breakup
dude him crying he's crying wow
talk to someone about it oh yeah he
should have been talking because he was
crying
i feel like like no matter what you're
going through
if you're going through a breakup video
a public breakup video and you want to
talk about it privately to someone who
won't tell it to people on youtube you
know what you need
space talkspace is an online therapy app
and it's here to give you all the
support that you need whether it be
breakups family stuff
some other you know childhoods
entanglement entanglements you know
mental entanglements that you have
um you can match with a licensed
therapist from the convenience of your
device no matter where you are
reach out to a therapist 24 7 from a
computer
or a phone and you'll hear back five
days a week
uh it's super affordable uh it's one
month on talk space costs about the same
amount as one
single in-person uh meeting with
with the therapist so it's way more
affordable and it's privacy of your own
home
and you can message them whenever you
want like for me if i'm crying because i
ate a whole entire box of rice
at three in the morning i can message
them at three and that's a lot of rice
isn't it wrong
it was raw it i have to go through seven
pounds of rice yeah i have to go through
expanded in herself yeah exactly
i'm not pregnant it's just rice um and
you can message them anytime which i
love because i don't want to
hold everything in and see them like
once a week i want to be able to
put out my feelings and what i'm
thinking as i go and it's not just
typing it's also voice messaging um so
you can just
rant it all out and they'll listen it
they'll listen to you you get to see the
full picture of the crazy that you're
dealing with exactly
screaming just the three minutes clips
of me streaming or screaming
talk space therapists have experience
treating depression anxiety
substance abuse trauma relationship
issues food and eating and so much more
the bottom line is that we all need to
talk sometimes and talkspace wants to
give you the support that you deserve
as a listener of this podcast you can
get a hundred dollars off your first
month on talk space
shares a whole lot of doll hairs to
match with your perfect therapist go to
talkspace.com or download the app
take a quiz um and tell them what you
want to talk about
and then make sure you use the code mood
m-o-o-d
to get a hundred dollars off your first
month and show your support for the show
that's m-o-o-d mood and talkspace.com
show them that we're doing our job here
you guys
tell them everything you have going on
in your mind mood i just picture you
sending a message to your therapist
i ate rice a good sad emoji he just
messaged me back gina
we talked about this it's just pictures
you can send
uh you have video calls too which is
really cool so last time i called there
was just rice all over my face
it was bad it was really bad he's like
gina i know
talking about erectile dysfunction isn't
easy either
usually guys try to brush it off or
they'll
come up with some excuses like sorry i'm
tired or whatever but you know what boys
we love you we want your dick to work
we've got something that can help
with roman it's
it will make it easy to talk about with
a real doctor who can prescribe real
medication to help you it's
simple safe and totally discreet with
roman you can get a free online
evaluation and ongoing care for ed
all from the comfort and privacy of your
home a doctor will work with you to
find the best treatment plan if
medication is appropriate roman will
ship it to you with free two-day
shipping
the whole process is pretty
straightforward simple and discreet
and getting started is actually simple
you can go to
getroman.com big mood to complete your
online visit
erectile dysfunction used to be tough to
tackle especially in person
with a doctor maybe it feels
uncomfortable but now you can just do it
from the comfort of your home
super easy complete an online visit
today to connect with the doctor and
take care of it
again go to getroman.com big mood
if you're approved you'll get 15 off
your first order of ed treatment
that's getroman.com big mood
thank you for stroking it so well can
you swipe it on that is getbroman.com
big mood wipe it on and then you wait
for it to dry
you're good to go and then you shove it
and then you shove it inside rub it on
in there
i did want to talk about a little bit
about that feeling of like being in a
long-term relationship and not having
your needs met because i
me and joe went through that we were
together for five years and i would say
after the first
or second year the the remaining three
years were very empty
yeah very like no sex just and
and i feel like both of us wanted to
cheat so
bad and we didn't so i feel good about
myself that i could last that long and
like still be a good person
you're a better person than i will ever
but also i can never i would break it
off i fully understand
like i guess what maybe jada was needing
yeah so regardless of how i feel about
how she went about it i definitely
understand that feeling like have you
ever felt that in your relationship with
steve or have you like not at all
no not at all i mean i've felt that way
in previous relationships but that's how
that's how you know that's how i know
yeah i'm like i can be with this guy
forever yeah and maybe that's naive of
me because we have
we've only done seven years out of
forever only seven years in yeah
right but i will say that one thing i
did relate to
in that uh conversation was there was a
point where jada was like you know this
was four years ago but
um will at one point like in our
uh and our wedding or whatever said that
he could stand by me through anything or
that he would love me through anything
and i didn't believe that but this has
proven it
i think that part the
hardest times that steve and i have ever
had to get through are what made our
relationship rock solid so it's not a
lack of
fighting or a lack of problems that make
a solid relationship i feel or like a
long
lasting um foundation of a relationship
it's that
it's those hardships um so every time
we've had something crazy
getting thrown our way uh we've proven
to each other time and time again how
loyal we are to each other
how we're we're there no matter what and
i think at the end of the day
both of us just value that above
everything like someone that has your
back
that you know like if i i know if i
leave a room and steve's in a room with
a bunch of hot ass women i know he's not
gonna cheat
i also know that if someone's talking
[ __ ] about me in a room steve's gonna
have my back and shut it down um and
vice versa
so um it's hard to teach people to like
what's the difference between sticking
by each other and being loyal
and uh being like an unhealthy situation
like like
hurting each other like in like some
sort of a false prison
because there are some [ __ ] out there
like oh yeah he might [ __ ] cheat on
me 16 times
that they [ __ ] fist bumped oh yeah
that that was interesting
i was like that is disgusting i know
it's interesting also is that
the like the public have taken that
quote and are like two different
reactions what
is it it's the bad management life what
is who's what is that
at the end oh did that yeah yeah did you
know he had that movie what is it bad
boys yeah i think that's like we ride
together we die together
bad marriage for life so a lot of people
are reacting how you guys are reacting
but then there's also the other like she
bad other people
is it like that no the other people yeah
or it's kind of like that's [ __ ] real
like that's that's really
uh like there's people that are in
shitty-ish
relationships but that they end up going
misery loves company so i don't agree
with them at all
so i think that that's all about
boundaries like it's you have to set
those boundaries from the beginning like
if
steve ever cheated on me that's it we're
done like there's no like
stand by your man like no no it's
[ __ ] done so you don't agree with the
whole jada and will thing like oh well
he showed me that no matter what
he still stands by myself and that
depends because i feel like they kind of
left a gray area where like we don't
know
what they discussed was okay we know
that
he was done with her ass you know did
they say hey let's try being separated
we got a strong relationship maybe not
but
maybe i mean there's some people that
have separated
um maybe they had this like itch that
they
never scratched you know like i know
people that got having sex with you
if you're a guy and they're they don't
want to they don't want to lose their
marriage but then they're also like well
i always wondered what if
and so they have to like scratch that
itch and then they realize like oh [ __ ]
this wasn't what i thought it was and
then their partner they want to go back
to their partner
and if you have that discussion
beforehand i think there's more of a
chance for you
to to have a healthy relationship after
i think that's a reason why
a lot of people end up i'm assuming is
why they
probably go the open marriage route it's
like oh
like i still have a we still have a
safety net that no matter
what happens we're gonna still write it
out
like a whole you can go and scratch that
itch kind of thing
yeah yeah so yeah i don't really know
they're
talking about what happens when it
actually does happen it's just like well
wait this doesn't feel good at all
yeah i don't think it ever really works
out honestly and by
looking at their relationship as an
example of them discussing it you can
see how [ __ ] up he looked in the face
like
it was not it didn't it wasn't good like
right
i i also wonder because i know
people can read things a million
different ways and we don't really know
the
the truth the real real right um and it
could be
too like you know she made that that
mention of
i think you've already got your revenge
we don't know what that's about right it
could be too that like maybe
he did have all his girls signed ndas
and she didn't and then she [ __ ] up in
that sense maybe he's mad that right
this is
creating a stain on their relationship
when before
it doesn't look like i don't know i feel
like when another man comes in and takes
your territory as well as a man that's
probably really difficult to deal with
and like the fact that everyone knows
now that she was with this young buck
you know like
i don't know maybe that affects him in
some way even though like he was with
all these other women
it probably hurts his ego well one good
thing that came out of this is that
there's a lot of memes that's a really
good funny name
yeah they're saying how like jada and
future are probably best friends now
his future is like the number one
cheater in all of hollywood
so they're just like so like they're
just trading strats and stuff like
strategies and stuff so the memes have
been great thank you twitter
every time i hear entanglement i think
that that disney movie tangled and they
literally photoshopped the three of them
shut up so jada
is the blonde chick what's her name
and then the the dude is will and then
the horse is august
oh my god it's amazing i like these
it's so funny internet called twitter is
undefeated yeah
yeah i don't know i ended up seeing all
that and i was just like well
because like i've been kind of vocal
about how we've had our struggles in our
marriage i'm like it was kind of like
comforting to see like even celebrities
that and like that
that high caliber exactly high caliber
are
going through their [ __ ] too i'm like oh
that's really i don't feel
like as alone because i especially being
like i said in the public eye and then
getting
constantly scrutinized for whatever it
is that i'm sharing
or not even just that like even friend
groups or whatever like
there's just certain aspects like a a
lens that is now being viewed
like that we our marriage is being
viewed through and that's like
our fault right or my fault mainly
because casey doesn't really
say anything but it's been mainly my
fault as to why we're being perceived
that way
because i share too much and then now
i'm like well now i know yeah that
happened
if you guys can do it like all three of
you guys can do it all over again and
you were able to make
um a brand that doesn't have to involve
your significant other at all like you
got you know you know
would you guys do it the same way all
over again or would you keep it private
your relationship
i want to say i would keep it private
but then trying to be positive
i won't because it's shaping me into the
person that i am right okay how about
you jess
if you if you can go back to joe saying
hey do you want to be on an episode or
be public what would what would you say
well i mean being on camera i think
um i was always against that and i
didn't want to do that but then now fast
forward all these years later
we have a show and i'm on a show i never
would like so that part like that
changed me a lot but as far as like if i
could take back
like if we could just be like co people
on
camera and like our relationships not
involved they don't even know we're
dating or something like that i would
have preferred
to keep my relationship completely out
of california
that's how they were for a lot of years
on campus i didn't even know but i know
they were together
yeah yeah i didn't know when i was first
guesting on the show oh really
yeah well i mean they they told me
immediately because i was like oh you
guys are together
like and they're like yeah yeah we're
married or no they weren't married yet
they were like
yeah yeah we yeah i was with jk for a
few years already and didn't know until
they
became public well that's also because
i'm dumb and i don't pay attention
i'm the perfect audience to cater to oh
unique would you
do it all over i think i would do it all
over again exactly the same yeah
um i think i think everything we've gone
through has
made our relationship stronger and um
also like
giving each other the space to decide if
we wanted to be
to he didn't want to be known as a
couple and that was his whole thing in
the beginning was that like he was
known as a couple before whereas i was
never known as a couple i was known
on my own as nikki limo over here did
you ever get
hate in the beginning like oh this is
yeah really yes
because of that how soon we got in a
relationship after
people thought like either there was
some foul play involved or something
like
either he was cheating or i was a
homewrecker or whatever and that is not
how it went down at all
i'm a real i would let you reckon i am
so like
even like if you're in a relationship
you're like not even a sexual person to
me at all like you're
you're done right like there's a [ __ ]
blur over your face
um so yeah i would never have ever done
anything like that um
i i think that even when he broke up
and there was like oh he's single now i
told his um because
his best friend was like hey you know
he's looking for a rebound
i'm like ew yeah i was like i don't even
want to go
in that direction for at least six
months because people need to heal
and all that stuff so there was a lot of
that like yeah i did get a lot of pain
especially since
they were known as a couple and they had
a lot more um
of a following uh at that time and so
i was getting a lot of their fans yeah
to be able to deal with it how long did
you guys
like wait until the public knew you guys
were an item um we tried to wait a long
time but it ended up
we couldn't hide it like we were in a
lot of things together like sketches and
stuff and
we were just like really excited too
like we were like proud to be together
so it lasted like maybe three or four
months before
like it slowly like started we were more
and more pictures together and
stuff i noticed that when it came to a
lot of um
public announcements of a relationship
if it's a public figure
with another public figure then people
are more accepting like oh my god
they're so cute together
but if it's a public figure and some
random person they're like who the [ __ ]
is this guy
he's not even good oh really he hated me
yeah oh
that's so strange yeah that's like the
weirdest thing like if it's just a
random normal person
just out yeah yeah anything like when
she like married that was he a waiter i
think
was he i think the first her first
marriage was like
he was like oh i could be completely
wrong but i think i remember her first
marriage was just
like he was just a regular person with a
regular job
and it it didn't didn't last i think
it's a little bit of like
jealousy because yeah like i'm a
horrible person how come i couldn't yeah
that's very strange holy [ __ ] jess
that's wild yeah
i also think that like um i don't know
the way that steve and i
are like the things we like about our
relationship or we're both comedians and
so
i mean he was improv and i was stand up
but we were both did sketch comedy and
the way you write sketches is by doing
improv and like doing bits all day long
we just do bits
and so like it just worked we're both
entertainers so
it it made sense to be in the public
eye i wish i could just be a fly in the
wall in your house it's probably the
most hilarious it's
just watching you guys throughout the
day these guys are [ __ ] most of the
[ __ ] never
it never goes on camera like like we
we're always like
why don't we ever have a vlog camera out
when we start like doing bits
we surveyed just cameras in your house
that should be a thing just like a nest
camera
just take clips of the funniest [ __ ]
that happens in your house when you do
the [ __ ]
oh my god it's so fun one of our bits
that one of my all-time favorite ones
was um i would go around the corner
like he'd be in the office or something
or in the kitchen and i would go around
the corner and just flip him up like
this until he saw it
and then he would be like oh no and then
he would come and i'd hide and
he'd like get me this thing
have you seen that by everybody of the
two guys oh yeah yeah
yeah and this was before that these are
so cute
my only concern with this uh will and
jada thing is like
because people look up to them so much
and then they see them kind of going
through this
disgustingness and then they get some
sort of
comfort that like oh well see me
relationships
you're talking about relationships just
stop substituting me i'm right here
i'm sometimes right now but also
honestly there's a lot of people like
even friends back home
um that where i'm like well they're
going through all this [ __ ] and they're
constantly calling and crying about
stuff and then they see people that are
that they think are on a pedestal going
through it as well
and they're like well this just uh shows
me that i can't do any better if will
and jada can't do any better and this
well i think they're going through there
has to be a healthy balance of that
mentality because it's not healthy to to
view
all relationships as like everyone's
gonna be a disney relationship and
there's gonna be no arguments no
problems
it's gonna be so beautiful so wonderful
we're best friends
and then the exact opposite of that is
like [ __ ] we're hella toxic he's
constantly cheating
beating me up all these things but hey
we're still sticking through
there's it's like both ends are
extremely unhealthy
yeah that's nice it's like just be aware
of that that like that's not just
because will and jada are
like cool with the toxic relationship
but that's not and then it's also
toxic good for the like again
like we don't know exactly what's going
on in the inside we don't know exactly
what they like they're each other's
boundaries we don't know what
they're okay with and how they feel
about the situation so we from the
outside we can view it as like
that's [ __ ] toxic but we don't
[ __ ] know we don't know [ __ ] we don't
know what's happening inside we don't
know how they feel with any public
figure
exactly so then that's why for me like i
take the stance of like
well cool they're they're in it
they are okay with it they they're bad
marriage for life fist pumping and
they're cool
it's like all right you do you that's
your [ __ ] life and that's great
because i know what it feels like to be
on the other side yeah and get
constantly scrutinized
for whatever is being shared so i'm not
i don't subscribe to that whole like
they have a toxic gas relationship
that's [ __ ] disgusting i don't
subscribe to that that's why i didn't
want to judge like yeah
right because i know what it looks like
and everyone can interpret it their own
way
but we don't know the truth truth and i
also think that like
yeah like having like
wildly unrealistic expectations is not
healthy at all for
entering a relationship either like
that's why people come down on disney
movies so hard
because they're like oh all these
everyone wants this like me for a long
time
right and and i think that you can have
that for sure like
it can get there but to start a
relationship
expecting that with zero communication
zero growth
no exactly zero growth to get there you
you have to go through some [ __ ]
and then you realize how much you have
each other's backs or like
you know how compatible you are how good
your communication is that like if there
is a problem that you're not
enemies that you're you're working
together for a common goal
and all of those things factor into
being happy in a relationship and having
that like
that like happily ever after it doesn't
come
on its own it comes with work yeah there
is a happily it could be a happily ever
yeah
you have to go through all that like it
kind of shows you that in the disney
movies too and even once you get there
it's true there's always a villain there
it is like a lot like a garden because i
don't know how many plant nerds are out
there but i'm a plant lady and
you know when you're trying to grow
something from a seed uh you have to
give a lot of [ __ ] care to it and
there's so much that can go wrong you
can get mold
first might take care of the dirt
exactly there could be like
infestations in there you have to be
like really on it and like taking care
of it
and then like once it starts going you
just have to nurture that little like
little bit of growth
and be like yay like celebrate it and
like keep watering it and then once it's
a full ass grown plant you're like
you're
beautiful yeah you have to still like
maintain you can just walk away like
it's not it's growing now i can just
leave it
it's done yeah no more work no more tlc
yeah
that is that is the big mood segue into
uh we started a weed dispensary
anyways guys we hope you enjoyed that
that big ass mood today
wait can i can i do something yeah do it
done before i'm sorry am i allowed to do
what do you do you have permission
we'll cut it out if we don't like it i'm
just kidding
guys look at my shirt
yeah i'm starting to make merch so keep
an eye out where can we go
i don't have it i'm still designing
where should we wait and watch go check
out my instagram and everything on my
twitter i'll keep you guys what is how
bashful and cute she is she's like i've
never done this before
look at this is it atmosphere darling
it's at miss gina darling
so i'm starting my own little merch
thing again so if you guys want yeah
listeners right now it says villain and
then what is that some chinese japanese
racism chinese assassination
it's true it's true she knows it's
youtube
japanese truth don't call me racist do
not cancel me
uh it says villain in japanese and it's
the tattoo that i have on here
yay yay go get gina's merch also
subscribe so you can catch more episodes
please yeah write us on itunes five
stars hopefully please hope
please please please please like us oh
my gosh
they're already gone guys you don't have
to it's
fine we're using reverse psychology here
because that's what works on men we only
want serious people so
please only subscribe if you're serious
only if you're gonna commit one out of
every thousand subscribers actually gets
a picture of one of our buttholes you
never know who
so we send it randomly could be you we
probably already sent it out you didn't
check your email
you're gonna be commenting in this video
i confirmed i got one
bye guys see you at the next
entanglement